hello everyone thank you for taking the
time for uh joining this webinar my name
is tarun animal and i'm the director for
agilent's global environment and food
markets
i want to spend the next few minutes
talking to you and looking into the
future about the pfas lab of the future
so i want to talk a little bit about
what labs in the future that are doing
pfas analysis actually will be doing and
how they can maximize
and optimize efficiency and throughput
so in the summary of today's talk and
you know just what we'll be talking
about is we'll quickly discuss some of
the market dynamics and challenges for
pfas testing
we'll also talk about when looking into
the future what will be the offerings
from a full service pfas lab what are
the methods they'll be running and how
will they be doing this
more importantly we'll discuss some of
the driving factors and how these labs
will actually optimize
and efficiently run these pfas samples
so they can make maximum revenue and
then we'll also finally talk about what
affects these costs what can these labs
do to increase efficiency maximize
throughput and also provide the highest
level of data compliance and integrity
so without further ado let's all step
into the pfas lab of the future
so the first thing that's really
important and i'm sure many of you know
if you're joining this webinar is to
understand what actually pfas are
so pfas stand for per and
polyfluoroalkyl substances or poor and
polyfluorinated alkyl substances
the big difference being that a
perfluorinated alkyl substance
is one where in the alkyl chain the
carbons that are linked to the hydrogen
all the hydrogens are replaced by the
fluorine atom you'll notice an example
here is pfos where all the
hydrogens that are linked to the carbon
in a traditional alkyl chain are
replaced by fluorine atoms
whereas a poly fluorinated alkyl
substance is when some but not all the
hydrogen atoms that are linked to the
carbon in an alkyl chain are substituted
by a fluorine so an example here would
be 62fts
where you notice that there are a couple
of alkyl chain links that have carbon
hydrogen and the others have a carbon
fluorine link
so when it comes to both chemical
properties and also the way they behave
in instrumentation for a measurement
they can be slightly different whether
it's a per fluoroalkyl substance or a
polyfluoroalkyl substance
now
i'm showing a slightly older paper here
but it highlights the point really well
and what it points to is you know we
know that there are upwards of 4000 pfas
that are present in commerce and there
are many different classes of pfas as
well so this paper by wang at all talks
about 14 different subclasses of pfas
and you'll notice on the right hand side
when you look at number of peer-reviewed
articles you'll notice that while some
of them are well studied especially the
perfluorocarboxylic acids and the
perfluorosulfonic acids where pfoa and
phos fall under you'll notice that there
are many newer categories and newer
classes of pfas that really are not well
studied at all and we still continue to
find
new classes of pfas in the environment
so what this is telling us is that
our understanding of the p-faces in the
environment is very limited and we know
that there are potentially significantly
a large number of pfas that are in the
environment that we haven't measured yet
or we don't even know that are present
yet
when we discuss the pfas testing blow a
boom i like to call it a gold rush and a
race to the bottom
why do i say that because a gold rush
because there is a potentially a lot of
money that is associated with pfast
testing for example
an estimated pfas total remediation
costs exceed 80 billion us dollars
we've seen more than 400 million in u.s
dollars appropriated by the us
government for pfas testing treatment
and remediation just in
2020
and when i talk about race to the bottom
we're really talking about you know
different regulations i'm just
highlighting the case for the u.s here
where federally there is a
public health drinking water health
advisory for just two pfas of pfoa and
pfas at a combined 17 nanograms per
liter but several states in the us have
taken it upon themselves to have more
stringent and stricter regulations and
these can be many different
kinds in fact i'm just highlighting a
few states here there are many other
states that have regulation as well but
what i want to highlight here is when
you look at some states like
california for example they have very
very low like single digit part per
trillion levels for monitoring of pfoa
and pfos and drinking water and then you
have other states like north carolina
for example that have newer pfas like
gen x that have regulatory or guidance
levels as well and then further you have
states like massachusetts that have gone
more towards the precautionary principle
where they regulate pfas as a class of
compound and so they have a
drinking water guidance of a total pfas
of 17 nanograms per liter so some of
that and then again you have states that
use variations of this such as minnesota
michigan wisconsin new jersey so
basically the
the guidance the regulatory guidance in
the states is all over the board and
levels only continue to drop and more
and more newer pfas are added to these
regulatory levels
this is also a concern to water
treatment plant operators as well in a
recent survey in the u.s
71 percent of u.s water operators listed
pfas among their uh top priority water
quality issues so so it is um you know
in the mind of both wastewater operators
and also the public is as well
so before i go into more of the talk
what i'm not going to do today at this
talk is i'm not going to go over
the specifics of regulatory methods and
testing like you know epa methods and
astm methods and iso methods
i'm going to actually focus more on the
methodologies or the kinds of testing
and how to optimize them that a lab of
the future would be doing
but if you're interested in the
specifics of you know epa methods astm
methods how to do them to learn about
customer testimonials and look at
training and stuff
then
agilent actually has a link to pfas
testing if you go to agilent.com
directly
under the applications and industry page
we have an entire section dedicated to
pfas testing as i've highlighted here
and this talks about many of the
regulatory methods it has a number of
videos and webinars from our
applications
chemists showing you how to do these
analysis so you can find methods videos
application notes training and other
things on here as well so feel free to
check that out
what i'm going to highlight here before
we talk about the lab of the future is
to
highlight some of the challenges
associated with pfas testing
so one of the biggest challenges i
already alluded to is the increased
scope that many labs are facing you know
about 10 years back we only cared about
pfoa and pfas it was just two
and then in the unregulated contaminant
monitoring role by epa there were
monitoring of six pfas then we had
newer epa methods that had 18 and 25 and
we're keep increasing this list and as i
mentioned already there are potentially
over 4000 pfas in the environment so
we're going to see this increased scope
from labs having to measure more and
more pfas and quantify them accurately
adding to that we're now finding more
volatile pfas smaller chain pfas pfaster
have different n groups and different
structures that are requiring multiple
methods and techniques for analysis of
pfas so again this increased scope moves
into not only the number of pfas being
measured but also the kinds of different
and new pfas that we have to measure as
well
labs are being really stretched with
increased throughput because of the
increased demand and outcry for testing
of pfas labs are being pushed towards
faster turnaround times that are being
demanded but also like i mentioned
because of the new and different kinds
and classes of pfas we're finding we're
also having to find better methodologies
but also different kinds of analytical
techniques to measure some of these pfas
as well
another big thing with pfas is the
extremely low detection levels that are
required and potential background issues
because pfas are ubiquitous we are being
required to monitor and measure pfas at
low or subpart per trillion levels to
give you a frame of reference um you
know semi-volatile organic compounds
like for example epa method 8270 we
actually analyze these semi volatiles at
part per billion levels so we've been
asked to go thousands of times lower in
terms of analysis on pfas
all while these compounds are ubiquitous
we find them all over the place they are
used in our work environments and in lab
products so getting reliable analysis at
such low levels without background is
critical
and then finally another challenge
especially for the contract testing labs
is the fast
evolving regulations there are new pfas
to be method measured there are
different matrices you know we're also
now interested in them in air biota soil
and food products and other things as
well
we're also coming up with new
standard methods that labs have to be in
tune with but this also leads to a very
important and critical aspect of data
integrity and security and compliance
and so having to deal with audits and
accreditation for this data is really
critical um as as well so these are some
of the challenges that lab faces so what
we're going to do now is we're going to
take a step into the future and i want
you to think about lab of the future and
i'm going to talk about what this lab is
going to be doing
so for the rest of this presentation
what i'd like you to think about is a
short time in the future in a galaxy
that's really really close a full
service pfas lab exists that has
mastered the ability to get maximum
throughput efficiency and quality of
their pfas analysis so we're going to
talk about this lab of the future that's
doing pfas analysis
before that you know what are some of
the things that are going to change in
this pfas lab in the future you know
looking back
they're going to say well compliance
testing is is getting important now but
it's a huge thing in the future and so
it's only going to continue to grow
another area that there's going to be a
lot of focus on is around research and
forensics based testing to identify
where
contamination sources of pfas are coming
from this is going to increase
in the future
an area where we've only just started
talking about this that is going to
become a big thing in the future is
surrogate and indicator testing for pfas
so using quick tests potentially even in
the field where we can judge if there is
pfas contamination and if so if there is
contamination then moving on those
sample sites for further
detailed evaluation and testing of pfas
you know and identifying individual
pfas compounds is going to become big
and i'll talk about that in the next few
slides
turnaround times are only going to
decrease so there's going to be demand
to get this analysis done faster and
faster and as i mentioned also there are
going to be additional matrices that
we're going to have to be measuring pea
fashions such as air food commercial
products and others
data compliance and security is going to
become a big thing just in general you
know we've seen a lot of uh
malicious intent in in using and
accessing
data in the reason that's only going to
increase in the future but with also
pfas it can be a sensitive topic because
some of the contamination is associated
with
government sites and department of
defense and things like that so
compliance and security is going to be a
huge thing
the one thing that is going to go down
though is analysis costs both in terms
of the demand but also by labs becoming
more efficient and in tune with this
analysis these labs are going to be able
to reduce the cost of analysis through a
number of
ways of increasing throughput and
optimizing efficiency that i'm going to
talk about with this lab of the future
so for the remainder of this talk you
know we're going to talk about this pfas
lab of the future and i'm going to break
down the talk into two things
first i'm going to talk about what a lab
that is offering
pfas as a full service pfas testing lab
what are the kinds of testing they will
provide
and secondly we'll move into what are
the attributes that this lab follows to
maximize their efficiency increase to
throughput and also provide data
compliance and integrity of the highest
standards
spoiler alert this success is only
achieved by this lab of the future
through close collaboration with their
partners and when i'm talking about
partners i'm talking about both their
suppliers of the instrumentation and
parts and also their final end clients
the only way this pfas lab of the future
can be successful is through a close
collaboration with all these folks
okay so when we think about
the offerings in a full service pfas
testing lab in the future they can
really be divided into three
formats or three functions the first
thing as i mentioned is that this lab of
the future will be offering surrogate
and indicator analysis for pfas
so these will typically be
the analysis of like organic fluorine or
some sort of reduction products to
estimate pfas and this most common
examples will be
measuring for total fluorine with
combustion ic or measuring for organic
fluorine breakdown products by a gc or
gcms and then also potentially the
top assay and the piggy assays would be
important as well for this lab to kind
of provide you know quick analysis of
whether the samples are contaminated
with pfas and if so do they require more
detailed testing
if they do require more detailed testing
the labs will be offering targeted pfas
analysis this really is and will
continue to be the gold standard of pfas
testing where we will be doing targeted
quantification of a known list of pfas
and while the lcm sms analysis is
already critical today because we will
start to find more volatile pfas in the
environment gcm sms part is going to
become very important as well and then
there's going to be the addition of
several different and new matrices as
well for example
water air soil food consumer products
etc
finally and a big
area of revenue growth opportunity for
these pfas labs of the future is
actually an untargeted and unknown pfas
analysis so this is where they are doing
a non-targeted analysis to screen and
identify pfases that we don't have
standards for or that we don't even know
are present in the environment yet and
so here you have
two critical techniques which is the gc
high resolution mass spectrometry and
the lc high resolution mass spectrometry
instruments that will be critical in
identifying and screening these new pfas
compounds and a huge sub area in here is
environmental forensics as i mentioned
earlier with the coupling of chemometric
techniques such as
data analysis and data processing where
we can actually identify sources of
these pfas contamination coming from
that become really important
so the first thing i wanted to talk
about was this analysis or surrogate or
indicator analysis of pfas compounds
right so the goal really here is not to
identify specific pfas but it's actually
to identify whether there is potential
pfas contamination in these samples and
if so do they require individual
identification of pfas so the critical
aspects of the surrogate and indicator
tests is that they must be rapid to
perform have really quick turnaround
times and be able to do with an easy and
less expensive
workflow and instrumentation
so one of the things i want to highlight
is the measuring of organic fluorine by
gc based methods so there are three
different ways to do this one of them is
to just monitor for organic fluorine
peaks using a gc electron capture
detector and just then summing those
peaks up to get kind of a pseudo
concentration and then determining if
that's a high level that requires that
sample be analyzed further
a second way of looking at this is by
reducing the individual pfas to a final
product that can be analyzed using a gc
electron capture detector so this can be
done as well by either reducing the pfas
down to some end product that we can
measure
and then finally by reducing the
chromatography if the analysis is done
by a gc mass spec then this analysis can
be done really rapidly as shown here you
can actually do this analysis in about
four or five minutes and have really
quick turnaround times of measuring just
the degradation product or breakdown
product of the potential pfas and then
knowing if the pfas loading potentially
in that sample is high or not for
further evaluation
another quick way or a surrogate or
indicator way of analyzing pfas is the
use of total fluorine measurement by
combustion ion chromatography so here i
want to thank my friends especially jay
gandhi at metro usa to provide a couple
of these slides to explain this
technique
basically what happens here is the
system takes a single liquid sample and
completes both a free fluoride analysis
using the direct ion chromatograph and
then a total a total fluorine analysis
with a combustion technology as well and
then these two can be combined so you
can add up the total organic fluoride
with the free fluorine and then get the
total fluorine amount that gives you a
surrogate indicator of potential pfas
load in the sample and all this can on
the instrument be done uh really quickly
um now also highlighting this system is
you know it provides very robust
combustion efficiency so you get robust
data across different samples and it
offers a large flexibility of you know
injection volumes and also the ability
to go
low into the part per billion range in
terms of concentration and typically the
low part per billion range is where you
would expect a sum of pfas or
fluorinated compounds so so this is
really a sensitive instrument for what
it's worth and something that can give
you fast and rapid
surrogate information on
total organic fluorine
one of the slight disadvantages here is
of course it requires a solid phase
extraction sample preparation and that
in itself can actually take some time
while potentially also adding a little
bit of background to the system as well
so something to be aware of
but these are the surrogate ways of
looking into it the other thing i want
to highlight is you know moving on to
the second form where targeted analysis
of pfas happens and so here i'm showing
some examples from colleagues at
gustelle and i'd like to credit kurt
taxton from garcelle for this data is
the analysis of pfas in air this is only
going to increase and be a greater
factor of interest for us because we do
know and there are many studies now that
show that a significant portion of pfas
can actually volatilize and move into
the air and so that potentially is an
issue
one of the benefits of using gcms is it
can be directly coupled to a thermal
desorption or also
other forms of sample introduction for
air analysis like canisters and so that
makes it really suitable to use a gcms
for analysis of pfas
furthermore many volatile pfas are only
amenable to the gc
analysis so then hence using
the gcms is a big benefit as well so
here is an example showing an analysis
on a db 624 column where you get
separation on using a thermal dissolver
with a gc single quad instrument for
the perfluorocarboxylic acids
but there can also be some issues by
using a gcmsd or a gc single quad right
for example
some of these compounds have in sim mode
have very low m over z's for example
here a2 ftoh has a 31
and we know basically that you know
low mass equal to high noise and so this
could potentially have a risk of false
positives
but we can solve this and spoiler alert
the way to solve it is actually using a
gcm sms instrument or a gc triple
quadrupole instrument
here is the same spike of that 82ftoh
and you notice that basically the
gc triple quad instrument coupled with
the thermal dissolver completely makes
you know the baseline disappear because
of the background elimination you get
from using a triple quadrupole
instrument so using an mrm over a sim is
a big benefit for the analysis of pfas
and so hence we can see that using a gc
triple quad might be significantly more
beneficial than a gc single quad
instrument when analyzing
pfas especially in matrices such as air
where coupling it to you know sample
introduction like a canister or thermal
disorder is a big benefit
the gold standard though for analysis of
pfas currently is and will continue to
be the use of an lc triple quadrupole
instrument or lcm sms right
and so many of our regulatory methods
like epa and astm and iso methods use an
lcm sms for targeted quantification of
pfas and that's really not going to
change you know there will be three
different ways of doing this for the lab
of the future and that involves you know
where sample enrichment is suggested
where you don't need as sensitive a mass
spec instrument but you require
something that's robust and can you know
deal with uh routine quantification
then you also have the direct you have
the dilute and shoot methods which is
like the astm methods where you dilute
your sample with methanol you don't do
spe but then you just inject it on the
instrument so here you require a more
robust instrument with more sensitivity
so you can measure those low levels
without sample preparation and
concentration but you also require it to
be able to take a tougher matrix loading
on as well and then finally you have the
direct injection approaches where you
know you can use ultimate sensitivity of
the newest generation mass specs and
this also kind of future proofs your lab
a little bit right because as i
mentioned levels for pfas are going to
only continue to drop in terms of what
we measure and having the most sensitive
instrument kind of future proofs your
lab for the next 10 or 15 years so that
if those levels drop you don't have to
again purchase another instrument that's
more sensitive
what i want to do and talk about a
little bit more is not about the triple
quad instruments but talk about how
using lc high resolution ms here with
accurate mass actually fits into the lab
of the future and how they can use this
to generate revenue and solve new pfas
problems all right so one of the things
is using a lc high resolution ms
instrument can actually be coupled with
databases that are available either
custom open source databases or curated
databases for pfas like this one from a
vendor and you can actually screen for
hundreds of pfas in your sample without
requiring analytical standards or
without targeting them in the triple
quadrupole where you have to do some
compound optimization right so here's an
example of using this custom database
with over 150 pfas compounds and we were
able to identify without an analytical
standard requirement
some other pfas compounds in wastewater
samples as well so suspect screening
using libraries and databases is a huge
benefit and a potential way of
testing labs generating revenue because
now you can actually identify pfas and
give your customers additional
information with without very much extra
work required in terms of analytical
standards and optimization of the
instrument and stuff
the other way to use this is by using
you know chemometrics and smart
techniques of identifying new pfas and
i'd like to credit jeremy colmell and
his team
from yale university for this slide
where basically what they've done is
through the software you can actually
plot mass defect against nominal mass
and so here what it helps you do is
using the kendrick mass defect and
chemometrics you can identify a whole
new series of pfas from just identifying
one single compound and that's what the
chart here is showing with the number of
different kinds of pfas n groups but
also a number of different
you know different
substructures of them through the
nominal mass defect measurement and in
this case you know it's normalized to
the cf2 measurement
so why is all this important why is
producing this additional information on
a qtof important well this slide should
highlight that all right this is our
real wastewater influence and effluent
samples collected
and when the samples were analyzed
only six percent of the pfas compounds
that were identified were done through a
targeted method that is ones that we had
standards for that were run in the lab
so that 20 to 30 standards that you have
only identified about six percent of the
organic fluorine containing compounds in
uh these wastewater influence and
effluent samples
another 10 to 16 percent of the
fluorinated compounds were identified
through the databases that i talked
about so that itself is you know pretty
much tripling the amount of pfas that
you can identify just using those
databases that are available through
vendors or other sources
but there's still about 60 to 80 percent
of organic fluorinated compounds in
these samples that we don't know what
they are we couldn't identify them
either through the suspect databases or
the targeted analysis through standards
so what that's telling us is potentially
a large amount of uh fluorinated anionic
compounds most of which could be pfas
that is actually present in these
wastewater samples that we don't know of
all right and so that's where the
benefits of you know using software like
the chemometric tools that i talked
about in the last side and the lcq top
come in
the other tool from identifying new pfas
is actually the ion mobility coupled to
an lcq top instrument this is what i
like to call as the ultimate for tool
for pfas identification or the forensic
hunter because we can actually use this
tool to not only find new pfas but we
can use this actually to identify
specific sources of contamination and
where they're coming off from pfas as
well so for these next few slides i'd
like to credit aaron baker and james
dodds who've collected this
data on their agilent iron mobility mass
spec instrument for for pfas
so briefly you know what does an iron
mobility mass spec do as i mentioned
it's coupled to an lcq-tops the lcq-top
uses
the high-resolution accurate mass but
critically uses that along with
isotope patterns and isotope fidelity to
identify chemical structures
what an ion mobility does is actually
couples that and actually addresses or
or kind of also has a drift tube and the
drift tube can actually separate out
isomers or molecules that have the same
mass but different
shapes and so that becomes really
critical now because we can actually
start to separate out pfas isomers
why is that important
because pfas manufacturing can be quite
tricky and different processes used to
monitor pfas can actually provide
different signatures of isotopes and
other impurities as well so if you're
able to separate out the different
isotopic signatures then we can actually
potentially say what
mechanism was used to produce the pfas
and that can actually be linked back to
specific sources of where the
contamination is coming from so here um
aaron and
james are actually showing the
difference between an mp or pfas that
has many different isomers and a
standard that was obtained from a vendor
as well that is basically only has the
linear isomer as well
similarly here they're showing that they
were able to identify
up to seven different isomers of phos
specifically on the ion mobility
that was quite critical and then this
can be used for fingerprinting and
forensics analysis later on as well
the other avenue that i want to
highlight you know is use of the gc high
resolution ms or gc qtof and here i'm
showing the analysis of a more volatile
fluorotelomer alcohol the 42ftoh that
was identified by a gc cutoff
but the question to address here is you
know why is it important to have a
cutoff instrument an accurate mass
versus a nominal mass say could you do
this with a gc single quad well an
example here is you know when we look at
that ftoh we notice that there was a
loss of 38.
actually the loss is specifically of
38.0168 when we look at the accurate
mass and that tells us that this
molecule is actually losing an h2o and
hf whereas if we used a nominal unit
mass instrument
then 38 might have told us that it could
have also been a loss of an f2 and that
would have led us to the wrong structure
so hence you know this accurate mass
tool is really critical and what we can
then actually do is because we know that
specific classes of pfas
lose specific uh uh you know um
breakdown products like the h2o and hf
here we can actually trace it to
identify different classes of pfas that
might be present in that sample as well
and that's exactly what we can actually
use the gcq top for so these are some of
the tools that you know the lab of the
future or some of the methodologies that
they'd be using to identify new pfas to
quantify pfas and actually to make
revenue off of them
what i want to do now is to focus the
rest of the talk on how this lab can
optimize and be the most efficient at
running the most number of pfas samples
in a high throughput environment
so for the pfas lab of the future the
golden metric is return on investment or
roi this is the absolute critical for
contract testing labs and it's a
decision they have to make whether to
get into pfas testing on how can they
make sure the return on investment is
the best that they can get all right and
so with that what we've done is we've
divided it into seven attributes that
the lab of the future thinks about when
they're talking about
a return on investment
the first attribute is the billable
throughput and turnaround time
so as i mentioned to you and the figure
on the left shows the pfas lab of the
future is going to be doing a number of
different pfas testing
uh you know on an lcms on an lcq top on
a gc single quad a gc triple quad and
then also a gc and
an ic as well in other instruments and
so putting all of this data together and
submitting it to their client is going
to determine how quickly they can turn
that around because at the end of the
day the lab's revenue is going to be
determined by the number of samples they
can run and the price they charge for
that so the more samples they can run
the better
and the lab's turnaround time is going
to be dependent on the billable
throughput right so so the first lesson
to understand is that you know while
instrument speeds and the method of
analysis defines this turnaround time
also coupling this to the different
analyses is quite critical as as well so
that's something to think about and the
entire workflow is what determines their
turnaround time not just the instrument
analysis time
and that's where you know sample
preparation can often be the limiting
factor in the turnaround time
and so here is where the lab of the
future makes use of automated sample
preparation analysis
uh automated offline sample prep for
pfas as i'm showing here with courtesy
to our colleagues at lc tech is this is
actually a dedicated sample prep unit to
analyze pfas
and what it does is it minimizes the
fluoroplastic components
it reduces the pfas background
it also provides robust automation for
27 or 24 7 operation what that
critically allows labs to do is it
allows labs to do batching and what i
mean by batching is they can be doing
sample preparation while the instrument
is running the previous batch and vice
versa so that you have both aspects of
your workflow the sample preparation and
the instrument running at the same time
and critically if one goes down
it doesn't affect the entire operation
of the pfas as well
so what are some of the things that an
automated offline sample preparation
requires well this system will be
operated and equipped with polypropylene
bottles that are critical for pfas to
avoid contamination and also the tubing
will be uh fluoropolymer free
the system also will have the ability to
automatically use multiple cartridges
you know illusion into different
containers and things like that so it
allows that flexibility all while having
the ability to load samples and rinse
out bottles automatically with different
organic solvents
and finally it has intuitive software
with pre-loaded pfas methods and also
drag and drop editing so customers can
do different things on there as well so
this is how the lab of the future
becomes efficient in the sample prep by
using automated offline uh spe
however labs of the future also have the
versatility to run automated online
solid phase extraction coupled to the
instrument
so here really what happens is the
sample preparation is coupled actually
to the analytical instrument or the lcms
instrument here and this actually allows
much faster turnaround times because you
require very low volumes without
sacrificing the sensitivity of analysis
for this pfas as well
some of the benefits of the online spe
system are it reduces sample volumes as
i mentioned with really no loss in
sensitivity still being allowing us to
measure the low nanogram per liter
levels
it also reduces the solvent and internal
standards internal standard usage
because you are having to now spike a
lot lower amount of sample instead of
having to spike hundreds of ml of water
sample you're only going to spike like a
mil or two and it also reduces the
solvent required because you're treating
lesser amounts as well it increases
reproducibility and reduces potential
contamination points because there's
less human intervention involved and
most importantly it produces faster
turnaround time and faster
results because the entire method you
know coupling the online sp to the
analysis can take anywhere between just
20 and 30 minutes as against offline sp
that can itself take several hours to do
now it's not just about sample
preparation though in terms of
optimizing throughput sample handling
and storage advances can be a big
benefit as well and it's not always the
big things that make a big difference
small stuff in your workflow can make a
big difference as well
for example ptfe lining in caps can have
p p fast contamination and so you can
contaminate your samples by piercing
ptfe septa hence the lab of the future
uses you know specialized vials and caps
and this is a unique bi-layer cap of
made of polypropylene that is available
through agilent now that also allows a
potential resealing once it's pierced so
what that means is it actually reduces
and lowers evaporation of your sample so
instead of now the lab using two or more
caps per sample to analyze them and
store them they can now just use a
single cap as as well and that results
in in savings as well the other benefit
on the vials is using a screw top
polypropylene wires prevents any
absorption to glass and also potential
introduction of contamination because
there are no fluoropolymers in here as
well
the lab of the future will be running
pfc free kits and really you know pf
pfas are ubiquitous as i mentioned they
can be present in solvents filtration
apparatus teflon line tubings and stuff
and one of the places they can also be
present
is actually in uh the lc
itself right and so that's why designing
the lc to eliminate all the potential
pfas contaminant parts like
fluoropolymers and things of that is
something that agilent has already taken
care of we have a pfc free kit that is
available and it makes changes to
multiple different parts
that are addressed in the pfc kit and
the lab of the future will make
a use of this thing to make sure there
is very minimal pfas background in
your analysis
now another attribute that labs of the
future for pfas analysis must have is
multi-dimensional agility right so one
of the things i mentioned is the lab of
the future will be doing multiple
different kinds of pfas analysis with
different instruments and that's
important because you know if one aspect
of that is delayed then at least you
have additional means or sources of
revenue whereas if you look at lab a in
this figure that is only using an lcm
sms for analysis then they are limited
in both scope and the amount of samples
that they can run and if something goes
wrong or goes down with the lcms then
basically they've lost a big chunk of
revenue generation potential whereas lab
b that couples different analysis with
the gcms lcms higher
high resolution and other kinds of
analyses actually has multiple sources
of making
revenue as well and can increase their
capacity
but also
you know get faster and better
turnaround times as well and one of the
ways of increasing turnaround times is
actually reducing time and method
development and method
validation so tools
such as the
uh pfas mrm database for lc triple quad
is really important here this is
basically a curated database of 100 pfas
compounds that in a drag-and-drop
fashion you can actually add to your
analysis what this allows you to do is
to potentially future proof your lab by
you know making sure you have new pfas
that can easily be added on to your
methods but it also significantly saves
on method development and optimization
time because all that work is already
done in the database
so basically what it is is you know you
can easily and quickly you don't have to
buy
expensive individual standards and spend
unnecessary time optimizing the mass
spec and the
identifying the critical acquisition
parameters because all that is already
present in the database for 100 plus
pfas as well so this helps you you know
wrap get to
expand your pfas methods very quickly
a critical aspect for the lab of the
future is the comprehensive quality
management and this is where it comes
into play about you know
how safe is the data are you in
compliance and you have data integrity
and security tools as well right so
agilent takes this very seriously and in
our key features for our compliance and
data integrity tools involve you know
mandatory logging in so we know who's
using the instrument also role based
security so not that everyone has access
to everything but you can actually have
it role based that's defined by the lab
also adding and removing privileges
ability to
override
or override protection on the software
and you know method versioning audit
trails and electronic signatures and
things of that are really critical as
well
what's also really critical though is
the ability as i mentioned for this lab
of the future to have compliance that's
interchangeable and relatable to
different kinds of analysis as well so
the agilent software that offers our
compliance is the open lab ecm
and specifically in mass hunter it has
compliance for the gcms
lcms also for our software and icp ms
tools as well so this is important you
know and labs can always use a subset of
these if they want but knowing that it's
possible to expand out to the entire
environment as well and some of the
critical
aspects of our open lab ecm data
management and compliance is you know
the centralized data management long
term archival on a server
also indexing and regulatory compliance
to specific regulations along with audit
trails as well for multiple instruments
in the environment and what's critical
to learn here and to know here is these
are not just limited to agilent
instrumentation but they can actually be
expanded out to other instruments as
well for example when i talked about
earlier the metro
ion chromato chromatography instrument
that actually can sit in this
environment as well it actually does
comply and sits with our obit lab ecm
and can be used in this environment too
another attribute that is important for
labs to understand is fast but realistic
implementation times right and this
touches base back on what i talked about
also with the method development aspect
where what is critical for the labs is
not just to determine you know how
the initial cost of the equipment is but
how quickly can you get to running
billable samples and so you know if it
takes a lot longer to develop and
implement a method from vendor a even if
the cost is a little lower it actually
might be more beneficial for you to
invest in a little bit more cost of the
instrument but have the method
implemented a lot faster as well and so
critical things that are tied into this
are you know the availability of
services and support having the
technical consulting available from the
vendor and the ability you know and
their expertise to help you set up
multiple different methods and future
proof your lab with training and also
with you know having ready-made methods
and things like that as well so again
something to think about for the lab of
the future
the other thing to mention is downtime
costs right no matter what anyone claims
are the features
pfas testing instruments will always
have down time there's no doubt about
that but it come becomes critical where
in defining that downtime right
routine maintenance is expected but as
long as it's routine and fairly
infrequent then that's okay it can be
dealt with you know and can be budgeted
for what's really critical to labs is
not having unplanned unplanned downtime
right and here is where you know having
your entire workflow being robust you
know having good sample preparation so
it doesn't junk up the instrument but
also halting your operations from time
to time also having tools on the
instrument that help you do
maintenance very quickly and actually
provide you early feedback if
maintenance is required is very critical
as well then critically also making sure
you don't have software issues right you
know having simple software that your
operators are not spending weeks to
learn and relearn and also having
interchangeability right for example the
mass hunter environment allows you to
run that same software on a gcms lcms
icp ms as well so that cross
trainability of your operators is
critical as well
one of the biggest things that is not
thought of by labs is that they often do
not think about technologies to future
proof the lab right it's always looking
at things that can just about meet
regulations at this time that can become
a real problem though because as pfas
regulations drop you don't want to be in
a place where you haven't future-proofed
your lab and then are requiring to
invest in newer capital again as well so
something to think about there too so
when we talk about maintenance you know
i just want to highlight a couple of
tools that can potentially make a big
difference here is an example of the wax
shield on the agilent lcm sms tools
right what this tool does is it allows
you to clean your capillary and it
allows you to go and do that without
venting the instrument so by keeping it
in vacuum right so this actually reduces
your maintenance your routine
maintenance time from anywhere from six
hours to less than 30 minutes which is a
huge saving for a lab right just to save
that amount of time and billable samples
that you can run
i also mentioned that the gc you know is
important and will become important for
pfas analysis here i want to highlight
the intuo and the guard chip right so
the guard chip is
very critical and proprietary to the
intuvo and doesn't require column
trimming so what does this mean to you
it really is protect don't repair so you
know like i like to say here column
trimming is so 2019
changing out the guard chip takes less
than five minutes as against trimming
and you know venting and potentially
doing other things for the uh instrument
when column trimming but here is the big
savings right and a guard chip in
two-way instrument you just replace it
out in five minutes and there is no
change in retention time because you
haven't changed the length of the column
whereas on older instrumentation on gcs
you actually have to then do a couple of
injections just to adjust the retention
time again and this is lost time this is
if your method is 30 or 40 minutes long
on a gcms you're talking about
potentially being down for about two
hours whereas a guardship is a five
minute process and a lot easier to do
so when we look at that whole
maintenance ecosystem you know really
what you want is you want instrument in
intelligence and quicker diagnostics you
almost want the instrument to give you
that early maintenance feedback to let
you know right and that's exactly what
agilent is striving to do forget about
having to log you know in lab notebooks
and stuff the instrument actually does
all this for you it logs when
maintenance is required it tells you
when uh things potentially could be
dirty and need to be cleaned and things
like that as well so this is really the
lab of the future making use of these
sophisticated softwares to let it
determine when maintenance is required
and how it needs to be done
[Music]
now finally you know the other thing to
consider is always indirect costs like i
mentioned right you know having simple
software that is easy to train and also
cross train your different users at you
know if they can use the same software
on lcms and gcms and icpms that's
critical as as well but it's also
important to keep a track of everything
in the workflow not just the instrument
right and this is why keeping track of
the changing instrument consumables and
preventative maintenance becomes
critical and agilent has tools like the
agilent smart alert to do this for you
so really what this tool is is it
basically is a software you install on
the instrument and it actually has alert
set points and it will alert you on when
to do
maintenance and when consumables are
running out and for you to order so that
you're not left you know in a gap by
your missing things as well and then it
can also perform certain recommended and
routine maintenance so that it knows the
instrument is always running at highest
performance and this can be accessed
remotely as well so this all of this the
smart alerts you know the early
maintenance feedback that i talked about
is part of agilent's digital lab program
right the goal really is to go away from
where you are buried in manual and
redundant data entry so that all you
have to do is enter the instrument the
information once and it also is to
eliminate any operational errors as well
to make sure the instrument is judging
when these maintenance and things need
to happen and how they need to happen as
well
so the critical aspects of you know our
digital lab program is the end-to-end
sample tracking comprehensive system
utilization so it's always
performing at this topmost level to
eliminate manual tasks and also then to
provide and perform automated
diagnostics so that this reduces the
burden and costs on the lab right so
with that my thing to you is you know
reach out to agilent if you're
interested in this we would love to
partner with you through the digital lab
program to improve your pfas analysis in
the future
and the last thing for all labs to
consider right is you must consider
the overall affordability of your
analysis workflow and methods as against
just the initial cost of the capital
right while the capital cost is can be
can sound large it can actually
really be minimal when you think about
the entire workflow and how much when
you tie that into return on investment
as some of the things that i've
mentioned as well
so with that i'd like to thank you for
your time feel free to contact me if you
have any questions and if you want more
information on
agilent pfas consumables
instrumentations and databases feel free
to follow these links thanks again and
stay safe